what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and many of you have been asking when
can we expect to see the next trailer
for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
the second trailer which is usually a
full trailer not just a teaser but a
full one well great news for you today
Marvel Studios has actually told us when
we can expect new footage for Ant-Man 3
quantumania and we have the exact date
in almost the exact time on when to
expect this now we're actually going to
be getting what seems to be like a scene
from the movie Marvel Studios has called
this an exclusive look now Marvel
Studios is famous for this without fail
Marvel Studios will release a teaser
trailer then they'll release another
trailer or special footage exclusive
looks and then of course as we know
they'll do about a million TV spots
before the film actually comes out but
of course none of us are complaining at
all but this time they have announced in
advance that we can get a special look
at Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania on
January 9th this is the upcoming Monday
almost a week from now during the Fiesta
Bowl between Michigan and Texas
Christian University on ESPN Marvel
Studios announced plans to release a new
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania calling it an exclusive look
trailer now if you're wondering where to
catch this live it's going to be on ESPN
some point during the national college
football championship game which takes
place Monday and it starts at 7 30. now
if you're not interested in tuning in to
that at all it's gonna be released on
YouTube as well this is typically what
Marvel Studios does especially since
they own ESPN they can take advantage of
what is aired and like I mentioned they
do this a lot they typically do it with
the Super Bowls or really really big NFL
and college games in fact that's where
they do a lot of their exclusive looks
that and Good Morning America which they
of course own as well so it's really
beneficial for them but don't worry this
will be up on YouTube pretty much right
when it comes out during the game in
fact recently anything Disney if it's
released not on YouTube typically goes
up on YouTube at the exact same time but
sometimes it comes up a little bit
before so next Monday January 9th around
7 30 just keep an eye out on YouTube or
if you're watching the game be prepared
to see an exclusive look for Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania which they are
calling the trailer so be prepared for
the second trailer and a really cool
look where things are about to go down
in the quantum realm and the Multiverse
so drop how excited you are in the
comments down below what are you hoping
to see during this trailer let us know
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign